ok son succès bon c'est parce qu'il est
le patron
non guy quand même dit li ion elle a
pour nom mais en fait c'est vrai [ __ ]
peut-être savez-vous que steve jobs de
le célèbre entrepreneur à l'origine des
produits phares d'apple et qui est
idolâtré pour cela avait la réputation
d'être humainement détestable je suis
romain et vous êtes sûr mais l'idée de
culture générale sont fixés
[Musique]
selon les témoignages de ses employés
steve jobs était tyrannique voir souvent
foncièrement méchant
certains sont même restée traumatisée
après avoir travaillé dans ses équipes
moi je vais éclairer ce comportement
avec la théorie de l'entrepreneur de
l'économiste joseph schumpeter
il la présente notamment dans
capitalisme socialisme et démocratie
avec cette idée vous allez mieux
comprendre pourquoi steve jobs était un
[ __ ] quel portrait psychologique de
steve jobs pourrait-on faire à partir de
la biographie de walter isaacson mais
aussi des deux films qui sont sortis en
2013 et 2016
je dirais que steve jobs est intense
posted by gerard cerles obsédé ou
concentration et colérique très
colérique
du coup il ne laissait pas ses
interlocuteurs indifférent ça c'est
normal pour schumpeter parce que la
psychologie et le comportement de
l'entrepreneur ne sont pas ceux de
l'acteur économique normal celui que les
économistes appellent l'homo economicus
cet homo economicus il aime la routine
alors que steve jobs valorise ce qui est
exceptionnel notamment dans le design ça
l'homo economicus il fait de petits
calculs économiques de court terme pour
protéger et améliorer son bien être
steve jobs celui avait un projet à long
terme très risqué et qui lui demandait
de ne pas économiser ses efforts
prometteur en effet l'entrepreneur ne
cherche pas un surcroît de jouissance il
trouve sa satisfaction dans l'effort lui
même ok enfin l'homo economicus est
plutôt conservateur alors que steve jobs
et plus généralement l'entrepreneur est
un révolutionnaire
[Musique]
steve jobs ne se satisfait pas du monde
tel qu'il est la plupart du temps il ne
se satisfait pas non plus des choses
qu'on lui présente
il peut dire brutalement que ces deux là
encore là c'est une version gentil et il
peut demander de retravailler le design
des dizaines des centaines de fois steve
jobs était d'une exigence extrême parce
qu'il n'est pas là pour ajouter sa
petite touche pour faire le n + 1e
ordinateur ou smartphone non ce qu'il
veut c'est une révolution
schumpeter qualifier bien l'entrepreneur
de révolutionnaire de l'économie c'est
même pour lui l'acteur essentiel de
l'évolution économique
un agent radicalement différent du
producteur et du consommateur tel que
conçu par la théorie économique dans la
perspective de schumpeter l'entrepreneur
vie en quelque sorte en dehors de
l'économie standard dont il bouleverse
la logique gestionnaire et utilitaires
schumpeter explique que créer de
nouveaux produits et services que
choisir de nouvelles méthodes et bien ça
ne va pas du tout de soi c'est même
plutôt contraire à l'activité économique
traditionnel est aussi quelque part à la
nature humaine qui est attachée à la
sécurité et à la prévisibilité mais des
personnages extrêmes comme steve jobs
qui prennent le risque d'essayer de
découvrir dans la masse des innovations
scientifiques celles qui permettent
d'augmenter la productivité ou comme
l'iphone de satisfaire une demande non
encore révélé sans entrepreneurs le
progrès techniques resteraient lettre
morte
il ne serait pas diffusée dans la
société l'entrepreneur a donc pour
schumpeter un rôle crucial dans
l'économie et il est à l'origine de la
création de richesses d'emplois du
progrès technique et de l'amélioration
du bien-être
mais il ya plus il y a une dimension
presque mystique chez l'entrepreneur et
tout particulièrement chez steve jobs
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une chose qu'ont retenu les
personnes qui ont côtoyé steve jobs
c'est son intensité quand ils étaient
concentrés sur un sujet rien d'autre
n'existait quand ils croyaient en une
chose personne ne pouvait l'enfer
démordre
cette intensité elle était notamment
transmises par son regard au risque
justin cette manière qu'ils avaient
steve jobs ce de fixer intensément ses
interlocuteurs les troubles est
profondément comme hypnotisé ils
perdaient leurs moyens et se soumettait
aux exigences de l'entrepreneur cette
anecdote
elles illustrent l'intensité de l'homme
habité par une vision parfaite pour
schumpeter c'est surtout ça finalement
la vision qui fait que l'entrepreneur
est un agent économique exceptionnelle
et il est capable de voir les choses
sans pouvoir les justifier par intuition
c'est un peu un guide mystique on
retrouve tout particulièrement cette
dimension chez steve jobs qui était
fasciné depuis son adolescence par la
spiritualité orientale et ses exercices
pratiques comme la méditation ou les
diverses formes de jeunes on l'oublié
parfois mais le fondateur d'apple était
un peu un hippie au début
bien
[Musique]
en plus
comme dit
porter sa vision coûte que coûte contre
vents et marées s'adonner à steve jobs
dans le charisme particulier qui
réussissait à embarquer les plus
sceptiques dans ses aventures
regardez dans ce petit extrait comme il
était charismatique à l'entrepreneur de
schumpeter à une vision dans le sens où
il est capable de se donner à lui même
un horizon inconnu radicalement
incertain qui ne relèvent pas de
l'anticipation rationnelle et d'y mettre
toute sa foi il est à la fois motivé par
le désir de renouveler la réalité
économique et par l'ambition de créer un
empire qui soient le signe de sa
puissance l'économiste ajoute dans sa
théorie deux éléments intéressants
le premier c'est qu'il voit un rôle
sociologique à l'entrepreneur pour lui
l'entrepreneur ne vient pas de la
bourgeoisie il est un aventurier inspiré
dont les valeurs et la psychologie tout
entier tourné vers le risque sont
contraires à l'éthique bourgeoise elle
vouée à la sécurité et au confort mais
l'entrepreneur à succès s'agrègent et la
bourgeoisie
grâce à lui la classe bourgeoise se
revivifie et se renforce pour gagner la
lutte des classes ce qui serait
impossible estime schumpeter sans les
qualités de cette personnalité supérieur
oui
le second élément supplémentaire
intéressant de la théorie de schumpeter
c'est que l'entrepreneur serait une
espèce en voie de disparition
parce qu'il constatait dans la première
partie du 20ème siècle le développement
des monopoles et qu'il anticipait la
stagnation économique du système
capitaliste l'économiste a prédit
l'avènement de l'économie planifiée
ce qui veut dire que l'entrepreneur
était appelé à être supplantée par le
planificateur comme élément moteur de la
société
bon on peut dire sans trop prendre de
risques qu'il s'est trompé
steve jobs est loin d'être le dernier
entrepreneurs schumpétérien il a même
été dépassé assez rapidement en fait
aujourd'hui il semble bien moins
impressionnants en comparaison d'un jazz
le dos ou d'un lots de masques qui
seraient eux aussi de ce que j'ai pu
lire des [ __ ] en synthèse si steve
jobs était un [ __ ] ce pourrait être
parce qu'il avait vraiment la
psychologie d'un entrepreneur parce
qu'il était un innovateur très exigeant
et qu'il n'acceptait aucun compromis
pour sa vision bon maintenant je dois
reconnaître qu'il y a des limites
importantes à mon propos et il ne faut
pas se laisser abuser par la mythologie
de l'entrepreneur elle ne prospèrent
peut-être pas à toutes les époques mais
en tout cas à la nôtre ça me semble
certain avec laura de la silicon valley
[Musique]
la mythologie de l'entrepreneur elle est
entretenue par la légende de steve jobs
mais la théorie de schumpeter lui donne
aussi beaucoup de crédit je suis plutôt
d'accord pour dire que l'entrepreneur
est utile à l'économie mais pas pour
dire qu'il est une personnalité
supérieur l'entrepreneur ça n'est pas
que steve jobs
elon musk woods hole ce sont aussi et
surtout le boucher le boulanger et le
marchand de bière pour parler comme adam
smith
même s'il ne révolutionne pas l'économie
ils lui sont très utiles à leur échelle
et peut-être même plus que les
entrepreneurs star enfin mythologie de
l'entrepreneur elle a également tendance
à gommer le fait que les grands
accomplissements sont forcément le fruit
d'une équipe qui fait que nous nous
approchons de miramax
alors certains entrepreneurs comme steve
jobs a réussi à coordonner et à guider
de grand talent individuel mais il est
raisonnable d'imaginer qu'on lui prête
beaucoup plus que ce dont il est
effectivement à l'origine mais bon on ne
prête qu'aux riches commandés si vous
avez aimé la vidéo mettez lui un pouce
bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour
être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante
pour lire ma synthèse de la conception
de l'entrepreneur de schumpeter ou pour
lire directement au capitalisme
socialisme et démocratie
les liens sont dans la description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser vos
commentaires et pour recevoir les
dernières idées de culture générale
synthétiser un enfant m'a le plus clair
possible
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la
newsletter en laissant votre adresse
email sur le site
je suis romain et vous étiez sûr mais
l'idée de culture générale
rappelez vous vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]
non